on va faire un point à présent sur la
diplomatique qui s'activent nouveau
round de négociations ce mardi à
istanbul en turquie l'objectif a minima
c'est de résoudre les problèmes
humanitaires le but ultime c'est de
décrocher un cessez-le-feu stable on en
est encore loin mais la tonalité de ces
pourparlers en tout cas de ce mardi
tonalité plutôt positive écouter ludovic
de foucault il est sur place pour france
elle et les pourparlers au moins pour
aujourd'hui sont finis ils auront duré
quatre heures entrecoupée de plusieurs
pauses c'est une demi heure de
négociations et une demi heure de
consultation de concertation parfois des
déclarations à la presse c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui surtout les négociateurs
ukrainiens qui se sont prononcés qui se
sont exprimés face à la presse même si
le chef de la délégation russe a parlé
de discussions constructives pour les
négociateurs ukrainiens il ya assez de
développement et de propositions un côté
ukrainien pour qu'on passe maintenant à
l'échelon supérieur c'est-à-dire à une
rencontre directe entre les présidents
zelensky et poutine et la tonalité des
déclarations des négociateurs ukrainiens
c'est en gros la balle est dans le camp
russe alors qu'elles sont dans le détail
les propositions qu'on fait les
négociateurs ukrainiens d'abord le
statut de la crimée les négociateurs se
disent prêts à ouvrir des consultations
pour discuter du statut de la crimée
pour les 15 prochaines années on sent
peut-être poindre une concession en ce
qui concerne la crimée un discours bien
différent c'est concerne évidemment les
autres territoires manière contestée que
sont le loin ce que ou le dombass là le
plus gros point le point clé pour les
négociateurs ukrainiens c'est la
proposition d'un mécanisme de sécurité
internationale qui doit être adopté par
la russie c'est vraiment ça qu'on dit
les négociateurs ukrainiens si la russie
n'accepte pas ce mécanisme est bien on
ne pourra pas parler de neutralité ou de
dénucléarisation de l'ukraine est ce
mécanisme l'ukraine souhaite qu'il soit
fait sur le modèle de l'article 5 de
l'otan c'est-à-dire que l'ukraine dit
nous sommes d'accord pour ne pas être
membre de l'alliance mais nous exigeons
des garanties internationales de
sécurité c'est-à-dire des pays qui
serait garant qui seraient des parrains
et que nous aurions droit de consulter
si nous sommes attaqués qui aurait le
droit donc d'intervenir nous nous
engageons je cite évidemment un nous
nous engageons à ne pas avoir de soldats
étrangers sur notre territoire ne pas
avoir de bases militaires
internationales sur notre territoire
mais nous devons avoir le droit d'avoir
des d'autres pays étrangers qui assurent
notre sécurité pensée parmi ces pays et
les grandes puissances occidentales bien
sûr mais d'autres pays pourraient en
faire partie c'est ce qu'ont annoncé les
négociateurs ukrainiens d'autres pays
comme israël le canada la pologne et la
turquie en parlant de turquie le
ministre turc des affaires étrangères
ahmad luciano chelou doit s'exprimer
dans les minutes qui viennent on attend
sa déclaration on devrait avoir un 2e 2e
journée de ce nouveau cycle de
négociations ici même à istanbul demain
dans cette annexe du palais de
dolmabahçe que vous apercevez peut-être
derrière moi ludovic de foucauld tout à
l'heure